[Music]
you still talking to your friends
it's complicated many a deer
has to fall
[Music]
anthony this is uh martha and bethany
this is mr grandfather nice to meet you
morning sorry to barge in on you you're
not barging he's barging milo walker
did you guys see spencer
i think he went back in we gotta go get
him are you out of your mind
we haven't even picked our guys yet oh
spencer huh what who are you
oh my god you're spencer's grandfather
are we in florida and you milo walker
did i die and turn into some kind of a
small
muscular boy scout are we dead
bethany no no no french
i'm the old fat dude this can't be
happening
my hip sure feels good now look at my
thighs look at your ties look at my
thighs
okay we have some issues here the game
is busted it was a game
i'm not it i don't want to be it
welcome to jumanji
this next adventure is even more
challenging and remember the future of
jumanji is in your hands
i have one important question who is
jumanji
is that barbara's boy we got to die we
did die are we in hell i knew it oh my
god
this is a whole new thing let me know
you got to have eyes in the back of your
head
what in the sam hill
what the hell is this it's your
strengths and weaknesses smoldering
intensity it's this stupid face you make
huh
what's going on you having a heart
attack breathe breathe this whole left
side is shutting down eddie
[Music]
you